years who have made this an
unforgettable evening great talent thank
you very much so tonight we come
together to celebrate American life
history culture and the eternal legacy
of President Abraham Lincoln I want to
thank all of the chairs of the gala
including your honorary co-chair
America's beloved first lady oh I'd love
to have her poll numbers how do I get
her poll numbers Kevin John and they do
love you
we're honored to be joined by many
members of my cabinet thank you very
much and members of Congress many
friends and distinguished guests very
distinguished as a matter of fact a
special thanks to our host and my good
friend for a long time Larry Gatlin and
his brothers as well as the chair of
Ford's Theater Board of Trustees Phoebe
thank you very much what a job
and finally to Paul Tatro in the way you
rent up those stairs Paul I was gonna do
it but I didn't want to take a chance
and the entire staff of Ford's Theater
thank you very much for everything
you've done this is an event that we
hope to be here what do you figure
another six times right six times at
least because we do want to preserve
this heritage and the center's treasured
legacy I also want to congratulate
tonight's Lincoln medal recipients a man
had a lot of respect for General Colin
Powell and his wife Alma and maybe even
more respect to you Alva great job great
job thank you and and thank you for your
service to our nation you have been
outstanding to people to really look up
to congratulations congratulations and
congratulations as well to somebody I
used to watch a lot Mark Russell who's
been a devoted performer at Ford's
Theater for many many years mark
congratulations congratulations
for decades families from all around the
world and all around the country have
come to this very treasured place to
gain a glimpse into President Lincoln's
life and in so doing into one of the
most vital chapters and probably one of
the most interesting chapters in
American history during our nation's
greatest trial President Lincoln stood
for truth and freedom and human equality
as President Lincoln's friend the
renowned abolitionist Frederick Douglass
said Abraham Lincoln was called upon to
decide the fate of the Republic so true
he did not hesitate he did not doubt he
did not falter his faith was strong and
his unwavering in patriotism like nobody
else and he had great patriotism for
this country and for country men that
was quite a legacy and quite a statement
from another great man the patriotism of
President Lincoln has lived on in every
subsequent generation that has risen to
the call of destiny
and the demands of duty this week we are
commemorating another moment when our
nation and the entire world was tested
at the highest level the 75th
anniversary of d-day right after this
event Milani and I will board Air Force
One and travel to the United Kingdom and
then to Normandy France on that precious
soil we will honor for more than 150,000
Allied troops who landed on d-day and
the millions more who fought in the
Second World War as one people America
came together to pledge our resolve to
protect the sacred rights and freedoms
that these immortal Patriots gave their
very lives to secure we will never
forget America's Heroes never ever ever
our duty and the duty of every Patriot
is to pass on the inheritance of liberty
and
that is the cherished birthright of all
Americans thank you again to Ford's
Theatre and everyone here tonight god
bless you and God bless america thank
you very much for being here